i got a question from marco can i use
cloud run
without him to learn about containers
yes
i use cloudrun without containers most
of the time myself i only use containers
when i need to load a binary software
package
which is not that often another reason
to use containers is if your team's
workflow is built around them
all right let's deploy a cloud-run
service without mucking about with a
container
here is a simple rest api built in
node.js which uses the express framework
pythongo.net and java code can also be
deployed this way
see the link in the description below in
package.json i defined a start script
which cloudrun will use
check below to see how the entry point
is defined in the other languages
and here is how i deploy it to the cloud
not a container in sight
are there really no containers well
there are containers behind the scenes
but google worries about them so you
don't have to
what are your google cloud serverless
questions post them in the comments
below